ce mois ci
l'objet du délit et du délire du délit
alors ce petit carré a changé malgré
donc je vais revenir tout au long de ces
douze minutes
mais ce carré d'ordre pythagoriciens de
dirhams 1 plus de +34 cadix a transformé
une grande partie de ma vie est vraiment
sur le carreau n'en parlera un tout
petit peu plus tard transformé pendant
les 4 éléments dont la phase finale de
feu qu'en belgique ou détruits napoli en
l'occurrence embellie donc fils
aidé d'une famille de douze enfants
d'aperçu fils d'une mère chrétienne
à l'école jésuite donc la rigueur
l'apprentissage est ensuite le
compagnonnage arles pour moi c'était la
grande école de nage de ce que je pense
que dans cette assemblée beaucoup de
personnes connaissent la vigueur de la
formation chez les compagnons et la 2e
db être c'est la faute à 30 m
et je crois que les balbutiements du
métier août et ont été donnés mais plus
tard je dirais pas la perfection parce
qu'elle n'existe dans les intentions
mais en tout cas ses disciples et cette
rigueur pour arriver à quelque chose de
que l'on croît être parfait donc ce
parcours compagnonnique ensuite sur le
chocolat m'amener à travers la vie à
dispenser des coureurs tout d'abord j'ai
été remarqué par un dessert j'avais fait
des musiciens jazz humaine avec de la
ducati du chocolat toute expression
ballack c'est à remarquer par un
pâtissier qui m'a demandé d'entrer chez
les maîtres pâtissiers france pour moi
c'est quelque chose avec ces
d'inaccessible la petite pâtisserie
chocolaterie confiserie à sa loup sur
semouse qui est un petit bourg de haute
saône et pour à cette étape grands
honneurs
je suis à me pisser d'écran
excellente école donc cette école des
changes entre les grands professionnels
ce qu'il ya deux hivers parents et là on
est tous les change réellement sans
réserve puisque c'est concret y avait
des démonstrations devant devant
l'assemblée de professionnels uniquement
de professionnels
mais pour moi c'était très concret plus
tard chose a mis à dos une autre
association la un échelon de plus une
marche de plus relève et c'est à
l'international ici en franche comté de
relais desserts internationale donc là
c'est seront à dire le boss de
effectivement le principal c'est à dire
la transmission démontrer ce que l'on
sait faible qu'on le croit savoir fait
et puis ensuite le mettre en application
il ya une réserve de 2 ans moi j'ai
jamais appliquée parce que j'estime que
quand on reçoit quelque chose
le devoir c'est de donner c'est le
principe du compagnonnage et suite à ça
un jour me demande l'écoutent azzouz il
ya un défaillance dans une école qui
s'appelle de nsp l'école nationale
supérieure de la pâtisserie c'est une
école qui est très cher les hameaux
professionnels le redis tu va animer un
pot de confettis chocolat j'avais fait
ça vous met le pied sur la boule
bananalotto dessus datong j'y vais j'y
vais et là donc ça se concrétise bien
devons nous demander chose de spécial je
te faisais mise en application que ça a
plu et par rapport à cette démonstration
qui était une première
ils sont nés suivi d'autres et j'ai un
copain mauvais y aurait de france qui me
dit me résous c'est la première
compétition internationale qui va sauver
la coupe du monde à la pâtisserie
chocolaterie glacerie il ya un 24
candidats mais il manque un chocolatier
tu devrais inscriptions se laver les
clôtures mensuelles sont intéressés à
gemalto et masques de fissurer jv sur
convictions mais quand même encore en
battant puisque c'est l'état d'esprit du
jour de france
or là je réalise
8h20 demande de faire je suis champion
de france mais autre que je suis
champion de france les des mof était au
jury travail dégustation artistique etc
le dise asus n'existe plus elle en
france tu te débrouilles tu prends tes
de garde c'est une équipe
et voilà il faut il faut bosser alors
pour la le but c'est en fait ce que je
veux dire c'est la transmission peut-on
reçoit quelque chose comme le disait
madame on est dans le bain des anciens
donc compagnonnage on est dans
l'indécence dans la tradition mais aussi
donc dans la continuité le modernisme et
l'évolution du travail est en fait pour
moi c'est ma vie c'est transmettre
je suis intervenu dans beaucoup d'écoles
dans beaucoup de pays du monde pour lui
dire ce que je crois savoir faire
conditionnel à ce qu'on ne sait pas on
croit savoir on sait pas vraiment où et
de cacao
j'ai souvenir au chocolat près c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'exceptionnel
parce que après cela j'ai eu
l'opportunité de faire le dessert pour
le bâti madina siaka de vierges avant ça
c'était quelque chose exceptionnelle
parce que c'est un tampon économique
établi entre la france et japon réalisé
par le général de gaulle à la demande du
général de gaulle pardon réalisé par
jean de la veille qui est à l'époque le
président de la chambre syndicale des
ssii française c'est à dire les trois
accords et du sna et moi on me demande
de réaliser le pca pour le 20e
anniversaire 600 personnes du verbe
outils comme rémy des olives à la place
vous savez j'aurais fait vraiment eu une
empoignade pression mais à chaud par
donc par conséquent concrétisation fois
de plus hélas 600 invités dont une
partie de la famille a par ailleurs
c'est que c'est très bas mais là j'ai
beaucoup d'habitations à revenir au
japon est en fait le déclenchement de sa
toujours sans réserve parce que je peux
je crois savoir fait
sans réserve et un jour j'ai une
conférence un petit débat comme ça
c'était la table c'est un kobe dans le
restaurant d'alain chapel est décédé
vous savez et je fais des petits débats
sur le compagnonnage le chocolat qu'est
ce que le chocolat mais je parle à la
fois du symbolisme cacao c'est à dire le
constat botanique de la croissance du
cac avait 4 12 36 ans rapportant que
symbolise donc tout ce que l'on croit
avoir fait qu'effectivement et sur le
sellette à côté ramenant quelque chose
de spirituel se sont produits en tout
cas on arrive à avoir quelque chose
d'inédit puisque le cadeau que n'est pas
vraiment l'origine donc c'est plus ou
moins que dans les situations de logan
nourriture sacré ça ne devient mais je
parlais tout à l'heure de l'objet du
délit
on retrouve aussi le délit puisque la
norme les normes européennes maintenant
tolère d'acheter ce que j'appelle du
surimi tchô place des produits dans
lequel est un pourcentage est là qu on
est en train de mourir avec ça lorsqu'on
pense que nous sommes un bon produit
en fait c'est aux hommes et ont exercé
ses cinq sens donc un individu resta
d'individus avec tout ce que cela
comporte et bien se nourrir c'est aussi
le renforcer et garder sa bonne santé
le chocolat va permis aussi d'entrer
dans et de faire des recherches avec des
étudiants kad merad et rama de pharmacie
faculté de besançon donc tu recherches
sur le comportement biologique numérique
et la haute cheval oui je la tiens ça
mettra tout est en fait grâce à cela
j'ai pu rentrer dès maintenant dix ans
dans la commission du professeur cabrol
christian cabrol cardiologue à paris qui
préside une commission qui s'intitule
alimentation santé
ça m'a permis de côtoyer des médecins
nutritionnistes dont hervé robert et
minorent nutritionniste qu'il fait pas
des chroniques sur tf1 écrit un ouvrage
qui s'intitule des vertus thérapeutiques
du chocolat et dans lequel dénigre
toutes ces idées reçues à propos de ça
donc ce qui est important pour moi est
ce que je veux essayer de faire passer
c'est que bien se nourrir c'est très
important
transmettre ce que dit c'est primordial
et l'expérience qu'on a reçu on n'a pas
le droit de le garder
secret ne doit pas exister bien des
petits trucs de petites astuces moi je
me souviens que j'arrivais court j'avais
douze professionnels
on partait sur la même base même recette
même n'aurait même même température
chaque fois un résultat différent
maintenant je vous montrais bons
principes de travail en fait c'est une
question de l'énergie comme dans le
peintre relevé le pain à l'euro à un
moment donné on aura pas une mais
l'ouest 1 que si on fait de façon
différente en laissant ses meneurs de
plus nos chocolats c'est une matière
très vivante et il va devenir
je vous le dis et j'insiste beaucoup
l'ordre noir de demain donc il suffit de
lire certains magazines dans lequel
parade économie et vous verrez que le
cacao deviendra elle devrait très
précieux mais sa mise à part ce quelque
chose aussi qui est très très bon pour
la santé et par conséquent donc il faut
pas en abuser
comment mon point de vue c'est
transmettre sans réserve
j'interviens beaucoup dans les lycées
dans les écoles professionnelles et en
disant au jeu alice il faut y aller
n'ayez pas peur lui l'objet beaucoup de
jeu de ce que j'ai formé je touche du
bois et du singe tous ont réussi dans
leur métier parce que je crois avoir
transmis une passion mais je pense qu'au
jeu il faut leur accorder la confiance
des êtres capables n'ai pas d'argent
certains d'importance veille de la
passion sachez convaincre les employeurs
vous est donc parce que vous êtes bon et
alice donc moi de mon intention est ce
que nous le message que je veux faire
passer c'est surtout à l'attention des
jeunes
donc ces jeunes ont ils ont l'avenir
devant nous c'est aussi le d'autres
puisque sans eux on n'existerait plus
donc par conséquent les jeunes allez-y
il n'y a pas de réserve la gastronomie
dans d'autres devaient probablement
ouvre beaucoup de portes et que ce soit
dans la confiserie le chocolat la
cuisine
notamment la boulangerie à beaucoup de
français qui s'exprime à l'étranger qui
réussissent parfaitement et en fait
c'est simple
donc mon point de vue est tout simple
c'est transmettre mais je conclurai en
disant tout simplement je crois que
c'est confus s'était dit profondément de
la vie et sachent quels jours et à lui
c'est tout l'objet du délit et tu te
dire pourquoi les japonais pour
apprécier ce petit arrive alors ce sont
des pures origines première plusieurs
présentations du même d'y assembler
leurs plantations d'altitude coja
baillet que beyrouth settat et des
premiers crus de plantation ce qui est
très rare c'est le cas aussi bien que du
plantations en toute modestie se
pressent à la romanée-conti chocolat
c'est pas de réprimer faso sierra
donc je prends le chocolat comme ça
c'est impossible pratiquement de congé
en une seule bouchée
donc on fait une dégustation est
conscient on croque le produit est on
active des cinq sens de sa tribu et deux
touchés on a une vision d'un cran quand
du produit on le voir le visualise
depuis loïc en marchant et en croquant
monde et qu'on dégage une odeur donc
l'olfactif est en même temps mis en
exergue
or ce qui est très important sic autour
du chocolat comme le vin il payant un
véritable débat donc c'est aussi pour
moi un sujet plus culturelle puisque
c'est très bon pour
cette émission je crois que des arts
dont des serveuses de la femme au lieu
des petits côte benoît la moralité mon
père normand ne pas ne mangez jamais
embrassé la vérité donc mise à part le
pli s'est procuré faisaient des
psychostimulants dizaine d'artisans du
médiateur ça débloque le bon cholestérol
en ruines le premier devoir de réserve
donc par conséquent moi j'ai du chocolat
et j'en terminerai là dessus quand on
goûte à un brésil un colombien de la
gascarie costa rica où vous vous trouvez
le vietnam qui produisait avec celle en
cacao
vous allez vous donner une sensation
très peu connue puisque pour l'instant
en france très peu de gens connaissent
toutes ses origines je crois que nous
sommes tous en france à travailler
réellement c'est travailler plus que des
bricoles sur l'autre produit très vite à
mon avis rien d'autre a ajouté il faut
merci votre attention